unsere musik alle mein name ist luca und
meine lieben freunde zur zeit haben
viele schüler online und recht und wir
schauen uns heute mal ein paar leute an
die das ganze nicht so richtig
verstanden haben
er hat in dem chat geschrieben
vorwärts epe question und jetzt schreibt
er unter den kathrein co
[Musik]
machst du gerade ernsthaft im online
unterricht
ob du verdammt noch mal auf toilette
gehen es ist ja aber ich meine es ist
nett dass wir wenigstens frage server
gehen mal frei hat am donnerstagmorgen
die pretenders projekt
[Musik]
das ist einfach zu der live act des
jahrtausends wenn man ihnen die online
präsentation halten muss oder gar den
test schreibt einfach so tun als hätte
man kennt ihn
internet mehr und das video wurde hängen
und ich glaub ich hab euch kann auch
ordentlich hinbekommen mai professor
elisabeth aus so meeting leichtes nein
nein
[Musik]
manche lehrer sind bei mir da hatten die
alle den humor von einem baumstamm
waiting to get back into
videokonferenzstudios kicken guter
lehrer und deinen verdammten stühler
kicken durchaus sein dass halt auch so
dass dinge die können wir gar nicht ihre
autorität dann unter beweis stellen so
online mäßig das wissen lehrer der was
ja das hatten wir schon mal trägt org uk
da kannst du den den hintergrund ändern
stell dir vor du kriegst du frage
gestellt stell dir vor der lehrer stellt
ihr einfach so eine frage und ein bild
wird dann so groß gemacht vom lehrer und
besitzer online präsentation im
britannia soundtrack gekostet
[Musik]
das ist altintop noch viel viel viel
besser als diese taktik von wegen hey
ich bewege mich einfach nicht mehr und
du sollst wenn man eine
internetverbindung extrem schlecht weil
hier weiß niemand was sie redet da sie
können einfach so tun
schweine kurzen halt extrem häufig wenn
sie baden gehen und keiner weiß man von
dir redet und jeder hat einfach kein
internet aber der wird schon über steam
aquajogging zugehört uwe barth thüringen
online klar ist okay das hat mir schon
so einen ähnlichen typen warschau blieb
die alle sind piece of mines and say you
cancelling kitkat slate sagte das hat
sie dann irgendwann mitschülerinnen
geschickt sie hat das an alle geschickt
auch an die lehrerin der nächste schüler
hat auch einen extrem guten live heck
und zwar immer wenn seine mutter ihn
fragt haye kann's mir mal irgendwie
keine ahnung beim abwasch helfen da kann
es mal den müll runterbringen sagt er
einfach nur am computer ich habe gerade
noch online klar ist
[Musik]
dass wir 1000 prozentig ich einfach die
ganze zeit zum reden die leute dir den
unterrichtsraum gegangen sind wo grad
halt unterrichtet wurde tschuldigung ich
habe ich im raum verteilen und dann
schnell wieder raus besten jetzt nur
noch jemand der noch online klaus rein
platz und einfach fragt ob er kurz mal
kreide haben
[Musik]
was
also ich hätte mich ja so erschrocken
wenn ich da drin gewesen wäre online.de
wer richtig blöde dann wird man
rausgekickt da muss man sich nachher die
wiederholung angucken was basically
genau das gleiche dann ist groß klein
musical klassiker von gottes
der real-profi hitlers krieg beteiligt
was die haben den lehrer rausgekickt das
geht doch gar nicht
oder hat ein schüler diesen raum
erstellt dann der ist für ein online
unterricht ist er hätte sich extra einen
leeren klassenraum sogar gesetzt du
kriegst das bundesverdienstkreuz
und wann
nein der sitze auf dem klo
[Musik]
erst hat er das bild weg gemacht
eine rentenkasse eingezahlt hat sich
einfach auf die toilette gesetz und
herumgeführt
warum schreit er die ganze zeit
[Musik]
also bisher war es lustig aber er hat
einfach seine lehrerin dauerhaft
beleidigt
war es das nimmt hier gerade kranke
ausmaße an nein hat er nicht als
gespielt gerade macht er wieder
irgendwas dass man darf ein bild ändern
kann ist in bayern fans gerne
nein was erlaubt sich diese schüler dazu
sagen alter ich will jetzt nicht wie so
ein typisch deutscher spielverderber
klingen aber diese lehrer machen sich zu
hause die arbeit ihren unterricht stoff
den sie sonst hat gelernt haben im
unterricht in einem raum den schülern
nahe zu bringen dort online zu
unterrichten und hört nur beleidigt und
verarscht und so weiter und so fort
alter das ist ja immer ein wenig extra
dem greenscreen aufgefordert mit dieser
online ein dass das muss denn sie hat
sich einer also einer hat seinen namen
auf seiner online-plattform zoomen oder
keine ahnung was sie da benutzen hat
derzeit heftigen beleidigungen
umgeändert selbst immer wenn er redet
lieber als diese beleidigung
ich finde das extrem unterhaltsam
allerdings tun mir diese lehrer echt
heftig leid anderer stelle durch das
sollten wir jetzt allerdings arbeiten
meine lieben freunde wenn euch meine
reaktion auf diese online school class
sales und live-acts whatever gefallen
hat dann das gern einen daumen runter
media und schreibe gerne unten in die
kommentare
ob ihr gerade auch online unterricht
habt oder bekommt ihr einfach täglich
extrem viel hausaufgaben per mail
zugeschickt wie läuft das gerade bei
euch ab würde mich auf jeden fall mega
interessieren und die findet jetzt hier
einen smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr da
draufsteht könnte meinen kanal
abonnieren wenn ihr noch kein abonnent
super dann verpasst ihr solche videos
nicht mehr ist kostenlos also klickt
einfach mal drauf und hier ist ein
anderes video verlinkt
ruhig
irgendwas machen
viel spaß beim gucken